it feels like I know you because I've
watched you on screen for so long so
I've worked too much I know you'll like
everyone's best friend but that made me
think of Sully as well and and how weird
it must have been for him to become this
here overnight so you as an actor was
that interesting funny I met him just a
few weeks after the actual landing and
in 2009 he was at it he was at a party
that I was at and someone said would you
like to meet Sully Sullenberger I said
the guy who landed the plane so I did
and even then I said how you handled in
this you know because it's a it's a
brand of attention that can look you can
really screw you up you know the second
act of this kind of stuff can usually be
a sir realistic existential crisis that
you can go on he did a very he didn't
off the good job of making his peace
with all of that he knows he knows what
he did he knows what happened and now
far enough removed from it to
voluntarily go back into it and kind of
like re-examine or recreate it all over
again my hat is off to him can you
describe to me just how surreal it must
be to see the poster where Tom Hanks and
your name on it as surreal as you can
imagine and then something yeah it's
just an amazing thing I mean who would
have imagined this is it hot for you to
watch say when my family and I first saw
it privately in a screening last month
it was a very emotional experience for
us and been watching it again a few days
ago for a second time it was much more
of a normal movie going experience for
me I was able to take in more the things
I had not seen the first time and I was
able to appreciate even more you know
the richness of the emotional content
the development of the characters and
the relationships that they have
especially Sully and Jeff I think that
we all sort of make a deal with
ourselves when we get on planes that we
could die yeah and this is the worst
thing that could happen in a plane
outside of crashing is that you're at
3,000 feet you have dual engine failure
you're in the middle of the city and you
know you have three minutes to get down
and you can't get to an airport I mean
it really it doesn't get worse than that
in fact on the checklist that my
character Jeff Skiles goes through and
Jeff told me this I mean there's
absolutely nothing
that even talks about dual engine
failure because they thought well two
engines aren't going to fail yeah you
know it's just impossible
so I mean it really is a miracle during
the plane saying I never cried films but
I started crying because it was hard to
imagine going through that and then oh
no it's no turning out hope you never
have to go through that incredible film
after doing this movie does it make you
think any differently about flying it
makes me feel better about flying yeah
actually knowing that there are pilots
like captain Sullenberger out there you
know makes me feel much better
I've delivered a million passengers over
40 years but in the end I'm gonna be
judged on 208 seconds